Với trở các dựng em mới, những qua tại hơn 1 trong dân hàng và gặp gỡ các nhà phát triển game là các hoạt động sẽ diễn ra tại Gamebus 2 không hay sấu,
không điều gì nữa đang chờ đời bản trong sự kiện game lớn nhất năm nay.
Gamebus 2 không hay sấu sẽ có hơn 1 trong dân hàng, người tham dự có thể trải diễn game mới, dần phần thường miền game.
Đây là không dàng dào đường trực tiếp giữa người chơi nhà phát hành Studio Game, đơn vị công nghệ và cóm động sáng tạo người dung.
Như gà đấu chuyên nghiệp giễn ra, gấp thể thào đình tới các phúc gia đình đầm đả.
FC Mowrow invitation kức 2 không hay sấu và chung kết cúc gia mùa bài này dần băng 1 xe 2 không hay sấu với mọi lời tỉ khu vực.
Cùng phát nhất mình với lời bài Game E-Sports 2 còn phần thầm và sức bờ nâu bà.
Gamebus 2 không hay sấu sẽ có 2 chương trình bữ diễn và giữ hành gật play.
Đây là người thăm dự có thể hoa thần thần cách nghiêm vực trong game anime manga và ph main.
Tại lẽ cho giải Việt Nam Game Awards 2 không hay sấu ngày 3 tháng 5, kháng giả sẽ được gặp giữa những người mặt use 내 gịch 2 CD Mỹ Uprise.
Ngày chính thân năm, con sớt tiếp tục khỏe đồng gamebus với 2 bốn kỳ Rồi, Guúp đi, Khăn Ki, Indike và DJ Quý OEG.
Gamebus 2 không hay mấy sấu sẽ giữ ra vào mệt tám và nghỉ tính thánh năm 3 SCC Hành Bố Hồ Dí Minh.